welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you too much information about how
one division simulated reality might be
a pocket universe that
we also live in
i'm eric boss and tumbling down this
conspiracy rabbit hole with me
is tommy bechdold hey what's up eric
hello everyone how are you
great to be here are any of us still
alive or have we ever been alive are we
just a piece of digital code and some
greater framework that we're unable to
see
what is time is there money in heaven
all of these questions and more will be
answered
hopefully but let's try to encapsulate
it in this week's big question
what is it this week oh eric the
question we have as we have alluded to
slightly
simply are we living in a simulation
[Laughter]
we're being for real folks this is an
important question
now more than ever oh [ __ ]
we're going there so let's do this thing
look i don't know about you tommy but
when that one division trailer came out
it hit really close to home
yeah for many of us and it's because the
way it
seems to be evoking concepts like the
truman show the matrix inception
that whole nagging notion that our lives
in 2020 are so nightmarish that it feels
like we
could be living in a simulated reality
this whole idea of a simulated reality
is uh
it's a conspiracy theory that is going
on let's say that out of the gate
there is no evidence to point to it
other than the lack
of evidence to the contrary which is not
evidence
but it is used as proof in conspiracy
theory thinking
i've connected the two dots we didn't
connect [ __ ] but i've connected them we
here at new rock stars like to keep our
conspiracy theories
as total conspiracies
confined to fictional universes
the truth is nothing is more true right
now for many of us than questioning our
reality and i
really want to shine a light on some of
these concepts so that you know
you watching at home don't get
accidentally sucked into
these things by accident which is how
they get you that's right
next thing you know you're believing the
earth is round and that we went to the
moon
we don't want people thinking that kind
of bogus [ __ ] so we're going to be
talking about the whole idea of the
simulated reality how
wandavision seems to be suggesting that
for at least this marvel universe in the
show
and by the end of this tommy my goal is
to convince you that you were living in
my simulation
oh no convincing needed that's a dream
for me i've been hoping that that was
the case
i'll be the puppet and you simply be the
guiding hand
easing your way up inside of me
controlling me
that invisible hand will never be more
visible or
more sensual yes oh god
well uh let's start from the beginning
where did this idea of a simulated
reality come from
just to give you a bit of historical
perspective here uh really ever since
the enlightenment
in the 17th century uh going forward
there were existentialist philosophers
like rene descartes who began to wonder
in his first meditation that
our perceived world might be an illusion
created by a demon to deceive
us he famously asked how can you be
certain that your whole
life is not a dream
[Music]
and that essay ended up inspiring a ton
of things like inception that
you never know that you're in a dream
while you're in it uh you don't know
until you've woken up so what if we're
waiting to wake up from this stream
around the same time actually a couple
decades later there's this guy samuel
clark who popularized that master
clockmaker theory of the universe that
the creator this divine creator pieced
together and then wound up the machinery
of the universe
and then stepped back so that everything
started to move in a scripted destiny
and he would never need to divinely
interfere with it
i like that a lot of this is religiously
linked right like
the someone above us created this
universe
and everything is connected to a
clockwork and we don't truly have free
will so
a lot of this has been intertwined with
a lot of religious thought but in the
modern era
in 1981 jean beaujolais wrote simulacra
and simulation sorry if i'm saying that
wrong it's a famous book
that actually cameos in the matrix
that's where neo keeps uh he hollows it
out and keeps all of his discs in there
the wachowskis required the cast to read
this book the central premise is that
capitalism has reprogrammed society in
such a way that
simulated copies of reality have become
our reality the example being disneyland
disneyland has become a place that we
seek to recapture the joy of childhood
but for most people that particular joy
never really existed we've always just
associated it
with the dream of visiting disneyland
but what is it representing it's
representing just other disney movies
that are themselves
sugar-coated simulations of darker grims
brothers
fantasy source material that's uh that's
nice uh that's making my mind expand
that's making me question everything
around me what's real
what's not i'm gonna break some [ __ ] in
my room and see what's real and what's
not
and what tommy is saying right now is
basically how a lot of people felt in
the late 90s when things like the matrix
came out the truman show came out and
x-files was on tv those titles
specifically
weren't just reflections of what was
going on for many people they
began it was the genesis of their pop
conspiracy thinking
in fact terms like red pill from the
matrix has now been co-opted
by many conspiracy theory movements as a
term used for awakening someone from
their bogus reality
and there have been a lot of studies
showing the increasing popularity of
real conspiracy theories like flat
eartherism false flag shootings
the moon landing being faked 911
truthers are linked directly to those
titles
and i i want to say when i say real
conspiracy theories i'm not saying the
conspiracy theories themselves are uh
making real statements
it's just that people really believe
this [ __ ]
yes very very important discrepancy to
make there yes
and that's what's scary about this
because of the numbers behind some of
these theories and because of the real
world consequences that kind of thinking
has we have to take them seriously and
talk about them now
i got a paper trail to prove it check
this out
take a look at this jesus christ and
really the most recent wave of these
series rapidly expanded between the
years of around 2010 to 2013
and what happened then well that's when
smartphones with constant access to
youtube
and other sites hit the market and got
in the hands of uh you know middle-aged
dudes with plenty of time on their hands
oh yeah oh no that's me
that's us that's us baby we're not
judging we're judging a little bit
because we have to judge but
a little about all that uh there have
been some thought experiments scientists
actually believe that within 100 years
we may have the technology to simulate
an entire universe
down to a quantum level including the
inner workings of billions of individual
minds so
let's say that like 200 years from now
the earth that we live on is
uninhabitable which is looking
increasingly likely and humans
interstellar like have had to move to
another planet those future humans may
choose to run simulations to test out
strategies that will ensure that
humanity
then will not make the same mistakes
again and they'd likely run
lots of simulations tweaking things here
and there to figure out which strategies
worked best
and that means there would be many many
simulated realities but only one true
reality
and considering the law of probability
we right now are more likely to be
in one of those simulations than not are
we not ah
terrifying you should be terrified and
you know we saw this in uh that black
mirror episode hang the dj right where
the the couples you know they were found
to just be
one of many many countless simulations
to figure out
how this dating app could connect to
people uh and a lot of people are saying
hey
it's possible we could be living in that
reality despite having no evidence this
is just conjecture
it sounds good to me i'm willing to give
all my time and money towards this
theory
before you do that you have to give all
your time and money to marvel because
they're the ones who pay the bills here
and we're gonna break down the four
specific elements in this one division
trailer that parallel
the real life elements of the simulated
reality conspiracy theory the first one
we're going to talk about is this
concept called
awakening so fundamental to all
conspiracy theories is a concept
of an awakening a cathartic eye-opening
moment
when that seed has taken root and you
begin to see
everything around you as part as proof
of your conspiracy theory of the
simulation in this case
so uh we've talked about the matrix
we've broken down the matrix on this
channel before but the first
act of that movie features three
awakenings for neo keanu's journey
starts with morpheus messaging him
wake up neo and then the true awakening
comes when he chooses the red pill
and he finally sees a matrix as a
clockwork mind prison from the outside
after taking it and the thing about
awakening is
once you have awoken after you've been
red pilled it becomes
impossible to go back you cannot see
your reality as you once saw it
so another example in the truman show in
the beginning of that movie a stage
light falls from the sky
and the moment truman sees that he
begins to question everything the seed
is planted
and all the fake illusory aspects of his
world gradually become
apparent to him before that moment he
would see some of these uh
onset goofs and just look past him he
didn't think to question it but once
that happens
everything changes now one division
seems to be following this pattern
because both wanda and vision's eyes do
go wide at the dinner party as they
realize they didn't know their past for
how they got here
the aspect ratio of their sitcom world
widens and it seems like each time wanda
realizes her reality is simulated in the
show
that reality might collapse and then she
adopts a new sitcom reality
interesting interesting yeah tommy do
you remember how we got here
yeah um
oh yes i remember okay i woke up
to the sounds of my roommates screaming
today beating on my door saying
you did it again you did it again you
fell asleep to blue's clues again
it's so loud it's on your bluetooth your
bluetooth blues clues it's so loud
you bluetooth blitz clues and that
sounds like a interesting redundant
statement that might cause us to glitch
which brings us to our second aspect
glitch glitching so uh glitches are
freak occurrences that believers of
simulated realities use as
evidence so this comes also from the
matrix in which the glitch in the matrix
was the deja vu black
cat
oh deja vu
what is it deja vu is usually a glitch
in the matrix there's actually an
amazing subreddit called
glitch in the matrix which i love users
describe similar experiences like they
receive impossible phone calls they
they have false memories that they could
not have had because they didn't live it
and then their brother will say oh that
person died before you were born but
they have distinct memories of that
person
it's fascinating i gotta get on that
because that happens to me
weekly like i experienced something that
i'm like i've done this before
this has all happened before maybe i
have powers maybe i'm the chosen one i'm
pretty sure you are
just eat this scoop and live on our
hovercraft and then plug in with us
sounds good the thing is tommy a lot of
us experience that it's only people who
have like a lot of spare time to
actually
think back and reflect back on their
lives because the way memory is supposed
to work
is your mind is supposed to erase and
recontextualize certain things
in a way that is useful for you going
forward memory is not supposed to be
like a digital data dump where you can
just go through files and objectively
read what exactly went down
our minds warp our realities
uh from our perspective that's why we
have this right to a speedy trial in our
court system it's like witnesses
their memories do change over time that
doesn't mean that we should eliminate
statute of limitations
for certain crimes right because we're
finding that that has been used to
defend people who've done horrible
horrible things in our society so we're
having a broader conversation about that
but uh what i'm saying is like
when people claim that they remember
something all the time we get our
memories
wrong there's a vast misunderstanding of
how memory works
but the idea behind this is that people
when they work with machines when they
work with technology we all know that
eventually it glitches at hiccups
because it's man-made it's imperfect
what they end up doing is when
confusing or strange or inexplicable
phenomena happen in the real world
they attribute it to glitches in our
broader clockwork machinery
so a great example of this is a mandela
effect that's when people
seem to be sharing collective false
memories of things like nelson mandela
dying in prison
he didn't or sinbad starring in a genie
movie called kazam in the 90s
he didn't yo tell me with this
or that the baron stained bears used to
be spelled as the berenstein bears
they never were liar
but it is amazing how like movie theater
employees will say i remember in the 90s
working in movie theater and we had
standees for sinbad dressed up as a
genie in a movie called kazam
how do i remember i for sure remember
that
and i don't it's not true that one was
the mandela one
i always knew he did not die in prison
the berenstain bears once
was fined by me i'm not a much of a
reader and i'm afraid of bears but the
sinbad one
that one hit me hard because i watched
his sitcom
his sin bad calm and and i was certain
that he was that he was in a movie
called kazam and it turns out i was
wrong there was a
nickelodeon animated show kablam there
was his name was sinbad there was the
shaq
genie movie which that was called shazam
right that was shazam
yeah yeah somewhere in there people are
misremembering and
it's amazing how they can collectively
yeah that's what freaks me out so we see
evidence of this in wanda vision right
so wanda's
reality glitches in obvious ways like
when she intentionally warps the living
room furniture around or she's aware of
it but also
in like other ways that seem out of
these characters control like when if
you look closely all of time freezes
around vision at one point in the
trailer suggesting oh this is how
they're gonna figure out that this
reality is simulated
so tommy my question for you is
eric eric
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry i don't know what happened about
that i just got a really weird
feeling
now things are starting to collapse here
we should move on to our next component
uh
government and media control so a huge
component of really all conspiracy
theories is that
all authority figures governments big
media big tech big pharma big financial
elites big
religious institutions they're all
conspiring together to perpetuate
whatever that lie is george orwell's
1984 a must read if you weren't forced
to read it in high school
this was a fictionalized tale of how
dystopian societies run on propaganda
double speak fake news if your world is
the media around you
that media can be controlled in certain
ways to spread lies
and force you to believe things that are
not objectively true
and sadly as we know history has
contributed to this belief
um not just now this has been happening
forever like world powers have waged
wars over false pretenses they've
engaged
in wag the dog scenarios that's where
they claim that there's something going
on but they're really doing it just to
distract from other
scandals that they don't want to talk
about we've seen cases of fake media
fake towns with rehearsed residents in
places like russia north korea china
other places there's false claims on
facebook that led to
horrific ethnic cleansing in guatemala
in 1954 the cia staged a coup and they
broadcasted
fake military events over the radio
pretending to be news just to demoralize
the guatemalan army
and what's shitty about this is once
there is evidence of that kind of
trickery happened
it discredits the real legitimate news
right people just say oh they're just
crisis actors i don't believe this
happened
right and that's how that seed of
conspiracy thought is planted
oh yeah yeah i i is
perfectly stated tommy uh one of mission
seems to be stoking these coals with the
shot of monica rambo
exiting the wanda pocket reality landing
outside and what's there
of course a classic x-files government
perimeter
and the question we're now asking is is
sword containing
wanda's reality warping magic or are
they observing it
also basing each of wanda's realities on
sitcom tropes echoes the truman show
there is something inherently false
about those multi-cam sets
and wanda's simulation using the
language of tv media to manifest her
worlds is
definitely reflective of what people
think the the moon landing was right
like they thought it was all on a tv set
so they couldn't believe it and tommy
i've been recording you with your webcam
the whole time we've been knowing each
other
oh well you have seen a lot of me
we'll be having a long talk after this
uh some of it is just for
just for practice eric i want you to
know i exercise a lot in front of this
thing and i apologize for the exercise
some of the imagery that you've seen
all right all right all right yes our
final our final one uh which you could
argue i've been doing this whole episode
is gaslighting oh i know all about this
i've been in a toxic relationship before
eric i'm an expert in gaslighting
we both benefited from and perpetuated
ourselves
yeah this kind of behavior so what is
gas lighting we hear this term a lot
there's no such thing as gaslighting
eric
there's never been gaslighting we've
always been at war with gaslighting
gaslighting is really the process by
which an abuser psychologically
manipulates and controls a victim
by using discrete lies by recoding by
implanting false memories they suggest
things have always been this way you
must have forgotten it's kind of this
discreet
casual reinforcing of a false reality in
someone's mind so that they're living in
the reality
you want for them so you can control
them really gaslighting is the bread and
butter
of cults and abusive relationships
because it traps the victim into
believing they deserve whatever
mistreatment or
oppression they're receiving and that
there is no escape from it this is just
how things are
oh my god it's scary this is the most
frightening one because it happens
all the time in all kinds of
relationships yeah which is why we're
talking about it because
it's a complex thing it happens in cults
but it also can happen in a workplace it
can happen within families
and we all have to like come up with
terms for these kind of things and talk
about them
so we can spot them when they're
actually happening and react accordingly
so while the other things we talked
about are core tenets of conspiracy
thought
gaslighting is the vicious one that's
the ongoing active method of reinforcing
the false reality
so notice how in the matrix the agents
continue to call neo
mr anderson in order to gaslight him
into their coded label for him as
opposed to the identity he has selected
for himself
in the truman show we see this
throughout right like his family and
friends are continually gaslighting him
with things like a fear of water a fear
of traveling oh truman you've never
liked to travel
i don't know what you're talking about
despite he clearly wants to break free
you know right now there is evidence
that i spotted in this uh one division
trailer of gaslighting with agatha's
agnes form catherine hans character
where she plays a role in that 50's
sitcom reality
this is gonna be a gas yes tommy she
says the word gas
yes that cannot be a coincidence nothing
and conspiracies are a coincidence so
tommy i think you should feel assured
because i've obviously never made you
question your reality right i've never
done that to you never ever no never
well there was wait no no you're
misremembering remember when i said all
memories were false and made up
and warped thank you right yep no you're
absolutely right yeah
yeah but no no uh so tommy i guess my
question for you
is do you think by touching on things
like a simulated reality conspiracy
theory do you
think this will help people properly
recognize
when uh that kind of thing is happening
or is it more likely to do as matrix did
force us to question our realities that
we're living in that is actually real
you're making it worse well this is the
danger
of free thinking just kidding i know
free thinking is always good
but there's you have to have a healthy
dose of skepticism
i mean healthy is the key word because
if a glitch in the matrix or a
distortion
in your reality is something that makes
your life more conveniently justifiable
like
everyone is against you that's why
things are going bad or
you can't get things done or you can't
take care of yourself because there's a
conspiracy against you then that is a
sort of paranoia
that we all can fall victim to that it
can be very
this dangerous however there is uh i
think a healthy amount of
you know brow furrowing you need to have
when you're watching
things reported to you or given to you
where you're like does this make sense
especially through the internet now
obviously there are real news sources
that like
are pretty watered down as it is but
like when you're getting information
from like a site called like cannonball
eagle
you might want to read through and see
if you're being manipulated
i just think for me the danger is if you
start thinking everything as a
conspiracy
theory then you start being able to
justify why you could be a shitty person
to everyone
that's what i am that's what i see more
in the red pilling is like
red pilling seems to be an excuse to be
a [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry
we'll delete that but uh no we're
leaving it in and i would not
uh i mean for me it's like i guess
call me a nice little robot slave yeah
yeah but i would like to
not be a jerk and maybe live under some
simulated pretenses in order to not be a
belligerent head
uh anyway no you're right on the money
tommy and we're discovering this in like
things like nerd media right now you
know recently they announced that
elektro's coming back for
spider-man 3. i got a lot of comments
people saying is this legit
the source was the hollywood reporter
it's one of the most legit
media news sites whereas people will
also send me messages they're like oh
this
one anonymous reddit comment said that
craven is going to be
the new avenger or something it's
confirmed right
it's confirmed yeah i can't put anything
on the internet that isn't true i heard
wolverines gonna be played by giancarlo
esposito
according to comic bonanza.org yeah
so that's why i think it's more
important than ever to go into your
rather than waiting for news to hit you
you have to preemptively
as a young adult determine what
legitimate valid news sources are and
and understand that there's a difference
between gossip columns
forums and things like that and things
that are real news
and you can tell things are real news if
they are independently verified if they
actually re they
have connections to the source and they
are connecting things not just through
one source
but through multiple sources that can
confirm and verify these things
and also whatever you feel about
publications like the washington post
the new york times when they report
something they have their entire
paper's credibility so much on stake
they lose so much
if they print something wrong and then
they retract it later if they do
as opposed to other sites that don't
even bother with that part and they have
legal obligations
yes there's litigation that can be in
the millions and hundreds of millions of
dollars as we saw from
gawker hulk hogan's suit against gawker
it's like to take something to print
requires is in that forum a pretty fair
amount of sourcing and
that's already done which is why i'm
sure eric you share the frustration of
like
when an article or a thought is shared
that is already attached to a good
source
the annoyance of someone underneath
going source
it's like the source is the thing that i
printed for you that is a very
legitimate news institution
i'm sorry i don't know who hurt you you
have been hurt by somebody that much is
clear
and that's the danger of uh political
actors discrediting
valid trusted uh decades-old media
institutions
just because they don't serve them or
they don't paint a positive portrayal of
them that's not what an independent
media is supposed to do
they are not propaganda machines and if
they're reporting negative things about
the president
it's because the president is the most
powerful figure on earth and needs to
have an independent media
criticizing the fact that he didn't pay
his taxes yeah or doing other negative
things don't ask
me don't don't at me uh but can you guys
believe this clown
just kidding that's a quote from the
debate shut up man well you shouldn't
don't you ever use the word smart around
me again
what an insane time we're living in
well let us move on to some people
helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at
doordash between answering emails zoom
calls and watching every new rockstars
video multiple times to make sure he
didn't make a mistake or mispronounce
the name of an obscure french
philosopher
descartes descartes de cartis i think
it's
gars sounds about right you don't always
have time
to cook do you tommy no never for me
it's all wendy's all the time
well not anymore with our friends at
doordash you can give yourself one less
thing to worry about let doordash take
care of your next meal
so doordash is the app that brings you
the food you're craving right now
whether it's wendy's or something else
right to your door ordering is easy open
the door dash app choose what you want
to eat
and your food will be left safely
outside your door with
the new contactless delivery drop-off
setting with over 300 000 partners in
the u.s puerto rico canada australia you
can support your local go-to's
or choose from your favorite national
restaurants like wendy's
like the cheesecake factory or like my
favorite
chipotle oh yeah they don't have
freezers there you know that eric they
don't have freezers in chipotle that's
how don't fresh it is they don't need
them
they don't need them i ate them on
episodes of road theory recently
made a little chipotle cameo many of
your favorite local restaurants are
still open for delivery just open the
doordash app select your favorite local
restaurant and your food will be left at
your door
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order for 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the code
big question that is five dollars off
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter the code big
question
don't forget that's code big question
for five dollars off your first order
with doordash
yes we also want to thank our friends at
native for sponsoring this episode
so my body is a finely tuned machine of
whatever snacks and drinks are within
arm's reach while i rush to get stuff
done finally to a machine in which the
oil
is oil from pizza cheese pizza time that
said
i do believe that performance matters
when it comes to what i put in my body
it has to do its job well my snacks
better found my tomtom up
right and my deodorant better keep me
smelling fresh all day long
well native deodorant doesn't just block
odor better
it is made better native has great
natural
ingredients like coconut oil and shea
butter it's also vegan
and never tested on animals ah i like
when they really put deodorant all over
the animals but
fair enough animals don't care if they
stink so we shouldn't force them to
smell better so that we can smell
slightly better
okay see aluminum forms a plug in your
sweat glands to keep you from sweating
that's why
native never uses ingredients like
aluminum parabens sulfates but switching
to an aluminum free deodorant doesn't
mean you have to sacrifice on odor
protection
native will keep you smelling and
feeling fresh all day long with
over 10 different scents including
rotating seasonals native has something
for everyone
popular scents include coconut and
vanilla and citrus and herbal musk
oh yes you smell good my favorite scent
is
eucalyptus and mint which tommy
smells like a koala was chewing some
spearmint
and breathed into my armpits yeah
it's just really refreshing it keeps me
smelling nice even after a long day
under the hot lights of the blue dungeon
which it gets
very hot in here it's like the surface
of the sun native is risk-free to try
every product comes with free shipping
within the us
plus free 30-day returns and exchanges
see why so many people
love native and check out the over 14
000 5 star reviews
do what i did make the switch to native
today by going to nativedo.com
bigquestion or use the promo code big
question at checkout and get 20
off your first order woohoo that is
native deo.com
bigquestion or use the promo code
bigquestion at checkout for
20 off your first order and now we move
on to some
bite size stuff we got one question that
tommy's gonna answer
our friend rob sent us this amazing
letter we finally were able to check our
mail uh
thank you for handwriting the letter
into us rob it was so nice to hear from
you
but if you read it here he was asking
all about uh
movies that make predictions for the
future and he talked about having
watched back to the future part two
recently
and how weirdly parallel that alternate
1985 is to the world we're currently
living in
so we're going to boil it all down rob
wants to know what movie got the
prediction of the future most
correct well eric and rob that's a tough
one to answer because
lots of movies and tv shows have been
pretty good at predicting stuff but uh
then have completely missed out on other
things so it's a little bit of a
credibility gap give 2001 a space
odyssey some credit
for how far out their predictions of
skype style video calls and voice
controlled robots like siri were
all the way back in 1968. and let me
tell you my alexa had me held hostage in
my living room last night for over an
hour
so it's no joke you should be more
polite to her i
you know what you're right i should stop
calling her the b word
beautiful however uh as is
uh 2001 space odyssey did fail to
predict
we have not uh had space tourism yet and
robots have not murdered humans yet that
we know let me know
so let's take a look at some other films
first we have back to the future
part due part two uh my favorite back to
the future as a child
it was made in 1989 set in 2015. here's
what they got right
google glass style eyewear proto
bluetooth headsets
flat screen tvs skype style phone calls
video billboards nike did make the mag
air designed to look like the shoes in
the film but that was more of a tribute
and uh you know inspired by the movie
rather than a prediction
what they got wrong was flying cars
hoverboards drone dog walkers but that's
got to be coming soon
wearing two ties at once sound effects
vests and they fail to predict the
internet
or widespread cell phones but they got
the world series right right they said
the cubs would win the world series in
2015.
i wish i could have put a little money
on the bubby yeah yeah
against the team from miami which is not
true but a team did eventually not move
to miami but changed from the florida
marlins
to the miami marlins so not bad i'm
still waiting for clothes that can auto
dry clean themselves which would be very
nice
your jacket is now dry i also have been
wanting to have my pizza hut rehydrated
oh you really know how to hydrate a
pizza man
oh yeah back to the future part 2 was
weirdly accurate
it's kind of creepy i mean not to
mention we have a very powerful leader
that is essentially donald trump living
in a casino
you know like that's insane and then we
have people who
have machine guns on their porches right
we have mr strickland speaking of some
restrictions yes two mcflies
with the same gun okay so next we have
contagion
the 2011 movie accurately predicted a
lot about our current
global pandemic including the virus
starting when a wild animal in the case
of coronavirus and coven 19 a bat
is pushed out of its habitat due to
deforestation and interacts with our
food system
the transmission and the symptoms are
somewhat similar they're both
respiratory
and yeah yeah you have to worry about um
yeah surfaces and stuff uh travel is
greatly limited and some forms of
martial law are imposed after violence
breaks out
hucksters are out there peddling false
cures i'm looking at you injecting
bleach into your body which was clearly
said sarcastically even though it wasn't
the president has taken his third bleach
injection and has made a full recovery
and also that also those women that were
on that like faith healer show
talking about like silver nitrate oh
right right right it doesn't cause covid
so you know what else doesn't cause
covid this dick
oh god you can't put that in
uh okay so here's what uh
that's just for the three of us here's
what they got wrong
the contagion disease uh the contagious
disease was much deadlier than corona
though they yeah
similar are not rates of spread so let's
hope that's not a look at things to come
there's been no evidence of people being
naturally immune to covet 19 like matt
damon's character was
in the movie contagion although i like
to think i'm pretty special
yeah yeah yeah we did a whole video
comparing right when this began
a ton of people watching contagion we
want to do a video kind of clarifying
how this is similar and how we should be
cautious and yeah
and how we should be put at ease what is
really scary about
contagion is by the end of contagion
they say 20 million people died
we have had over a million people die so
far
and that is scary that we're anywhere
close yeah this is
horrifying equally as terrifying
slightly less depressing note let's talk
about idiocracy
made in 2006 set in 2506 that's right
here's what they got right
fast food in the white house and boy did
they nail that one trump tried to
nominate andrew puzder a former carl's
jr exec to be the secretary of labor
i'm the secretary of state brought to
you by carls jr
cars that can be remotely disabled if
they don't pay their bills
that's uh terrifying and accurate here's
what they got wrong
dead crops due to watering them with
electrolyte drinks but there's still
time and god if
fuddruckers doesn't become butts after
they get over the chapter 11.
you had terry crews a pro wrestler as
president and people are pushing the
rock to run for president there is still
time
and donald trump is in the wwe hall of
fame so
anyone who's received a stone cold
stunner to me is
always eligible to be in the white house
looking at
you mike tyson all right we got time for
one final box of scraps questions
staying on the theme of this episode
tommy have you ever had a glitch in the
matrix
moment uh yes i've had some weird
like obviously i talked about having the
deja vu thing and then i
i have superstitions about like flying
where like if my flight's gonna be
changed i am
always agonizing over like the flight
that i was supposed to be on is gonna
land safely the flight that i have
changed to now is going to crash or vice
versa yeah we have clearance clarence
roger roger what's our vector victor i
think about like those are obviously
negative ones i have like a positive one
when i was 10 years old we went to
disney world for the first time with my
my uncle bob
took us with my dad and my mom and his
wife and kids
and when we got there our aunt
our great-aunt ellie was in main street
usa
with like distant cousin of ours whoa
she do like she's like she was like
their aunt as well but we had no
relationship with them
so we had no idea she was gonna be there
so we saw her we were close with her and
she was a really nice sweet old woman
and she passed away like two weeks after
that and there's no way any of us would
have seen her
again like you know we would have never
gotten a chance
she was old she was like in her late 80s
not to nothing that makes nothing that
ever makes it less sad but not
i don't want to say she suddenly died at
54 in the middle of a prime
but like we saw her in disney world and
like gotta spend a few moments i think
we ended up having lunch with them and
like
got to spend a little time with her for
one last time and then that was it
and then that was the last time any of
us ever saw her so
that to me was one of those like we were
you know based in rochester new york
with almost 2 000 miles away in in
florida had no knowledge that she was
going to be there despite being
relatively close with her
and also we just ran into her like we
were at a
massive park you know i don't know how
many people are in a disney property at
any given point when there's no kovid
but like i assume it's hundreds of
thousands we found her at the exact
point
and met up with her this was all
pre-cell phone too so it's not like we
could have texted and
you know made any sort of plans so
that's what i got for my glitch in the
matrix
i have a glitch in the matrix thing that
might just be a false memory that was
implanted in my head that doesn't make
sense
but when i was uh like four or five
years old my family went on a road trip
we
were from jacksonville we went on a road
trip to south florida to the florida
keys
we're staying in all these different
hotels along this trip there was five of
us piled in this
uh weird small van it was like this
particular
uh tan gold colored van that like it was
distinct
like i didn't see any other vans i've
never seen another van that looks like
this but at one point we pull
into the parking lot it was like late at
night no one is in this parking lot
we park in this part of the parking lot
no one no other car is around
it's like you know this this vacant lot
so i i get out of the car and i start
making my way to the lobby
across the parking lot and then i look
over
and my family is leaving in the van
oh god they're pulling out of the
parking lot
and i freak out i start screaming and
crying running
after that i have like my night night
blanket this is just like
toting like a cape behind me and i'm
screaming trying to flag him down
and the the car slams on the brakes
screeches to a halt and i run up to it
and the window rolls down
and it's like this man i've never seen
before
oh god uh just staring at me so confused
and then my brother calls over to me and
he goes
eric what are you doing and then he's
over there with my family
and i'm just staring at them confused i
look back at the car i just flagged down
it is gone
oh god must have i assumed pulled out of
the
lot but it was gone and somebody that
scarred me somehow i was so confused as
a five-year-old
thinking my family had left me behind
but it was just happened to be someone
else
who had this same exact car wow yeah
that is
bonkers it was weird i it probably
didn't go down exactly like that i am
remembering you know
over 20 years ago it sounds like a
glitch in the matrix
yes sounds like a glitch of the matrix
to me proof we're living in a fake world
hell yes well that is our show uh so
great to talk with you tommy i feel like
we cleared a lot of things up if you
have an interesting
simulated reality glitch in the matrix
moment from your past
share it in the comments below we want
to hear about it we love hearing these
kind of stories a reminder that you can
join our official discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars
you can get an audio version of the show
by subscribing to new rockstars big
question wherever
you get your podcasts you can also send
us your big questions on twitter using
the hashtag bigquestion
follow me at eavos follow tommy at tommy
bechtold follow new rockstars on social
subscribe here on youtube to get too
much information all the stuff you care
about
uh question everything including the
people who are telling you to question
everything the truth is out there
it's it's probably in a book a reading
rainbow
hi everybody stacy
[Music]
you